good afternoon and welcome to the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences makeup artists and hairstylists
symposium my name is Katherine Blondell
I am one I am one of three governors and
the chairman of our branch this year
Lois Burwell is our Vice Chair and
Howard Berger is your third governor
this year marks this 90-second Academy
Awards today's event titled Oscar week
makeup artists and hairstylists
symposium can be viewed on the academy
website at oscars org
so we welcome viewers from around the
world as well as those attending today
the reason the Academy gives an Academy
Award is to honor and celebrate the art
and science of motion pictures it's why
the Academy exists the Oscar exists
because the founders believed that
movies were not just a business and
people needed to be reminded of that the
Oscar exists to tell the world that
filmmaking is an art and it is being
practiced by some people at a very high
level some of those people are in this
room today and we would like to take the
time to introduce some of our past
winners so would actually all of our
past nominees and Oscar winners please
stand up so we can give you
[Applause]
[Laughter]
we would also like to recognize makeup
artist and hairstylist gild 706 and we
also want to thank ren de haber camp and
Alejandra s ba Sunday and the members of
the Academy staff that make this event
possible
please welcome Lois Burwell afternoon
everyone
so our branch is well aware how our
nominations are decided but please bear
with me while I inform our guests who
may not know our procedures in April and
October the makeup artist and hair
stylist committee meet as a part of the
meeting we discussed the list of films
that are eligible during the year this
year that numbered 344 films from that
list comes recommendations of films to
be seen for makeup and hairstyling the
list of films that have been discussed
gets posted on our Academy website the
aim being that our branch members have
the opportunity to see these films while
they are released on the big screen
reducing the number that need to be seen
at the end of the year possibly by
streaming or DVD viewing we encourage
anyone from our branch who has seen a
movie they feel should be considered to
post that title on our discussion board
to enable cinema viewing of that film we
also encourage artists who have a film
that will be released at the end of the
year to speak to their producers to
arrange a screening so their film can be
considered in November we call for an
all branch meeting to discuss the film's
then in December another or branch
meeting is called for to vote for the
ten films that will move forward for
consideration for nomination following
the December meeting the makeup and
hairstyling executive committee me
this meeting is to choose the maximum of
two names possibly three of those most
responsible for the look of the film or
character or characters this decision of
whose name is on the ticket is based
upon the input and work that was done
then in January all members are asked to
attend a presentation by the makeup and
hair stylist branch to see clips and
hear from the honorees of those ten
films this is known as the bake-off
there are no baked goods which is
streamed live
so branch members who are either on
location or overseas can participate and
vote Academy makeup artists and
hairstylist members spend a great deal
of time in an effort to applaud the work
of others to that end we also have to
thank our staff members at the academy
Tomoya and Michael Benedict for their
tireless support and effort to get the
work done
round of applause excellent so thank you
and now please welcome Howard Berger
Hey then my fan club
yes thanks everybody thanks for coming
so there are two stories that we we felt
we wanted to share with you today and
the first it's been told before but we
feel it's an important one so in 1968
prior to being a yearly Oscar for make
up Planet of the Apes was given are
going to receive a special Academy Award
that award as was the process at the
time would have gone to the makeup
department head of 20th Century Fox
which was the great dance tree Peck Dan
stated that the person most responsible
for this achievement is John Chambers
and he must receive that Oscar Dan was a
great guy anybody knew him he's he was
the best so it is that standard of
honesty and responsibility that we
follow today as the Kaz the committee
painstakingly chooses the individuals
most responsible for what has been
recognized in each film our second story
is about Leonard Engelmann Leonard has
been an Academy member since 1986 when
we were members at large
Leonard chaired several of our meetings
in championed our becoming the makeup
artist branch in 2006 in 2007
Leonard moderated the first symposium as
an academy program to honor support and
celebrate our makeup artists we have
since become the makeup artist and
hairstylist branch he has sirs served as
a governor for 12 years and he worked
very hard to ensure that we continued to
stand for the very best achievement in
makeup and hairstyling please join with
me to thank Leonard for all his
contributions
[Applause]
today is a celebration of winners we are
here to honor and celebrate some
incredible work in the art of makeup and
hairstyling every nominee that steps up
on this stage is winner only one film
will take carry away the statue but
every nominee has proven their work to
be exceptional by the fact they're here
today at this time I'd like to ask all
of our nominees to please stand
audience please give them a round of
applause
[Applause]
in today's program I will announce the
film what it is up for and you will see
a seven-minute clip to remind you of the
work after the clip I will invite the
nominees to the stage where while they
are being interviewed by Lois and Howard
there will be images behind them that
they will be able to refer to during
their conversation after their
conversation we will allow some time for
the audience to ask questions please
raise your hand and a microphone will be
brought to you so that everyone
including those who will be streaming
this can hear your question please limit
your question to one at a time and if
you have a second allow others to ask
their question first also please keep
the questions to pertaining to the
today's films and these artists careers
let's get started
bombshell
make up makeup hair styling and
prosthetic s--
please show the clip
and everyone in this building even Roger
answers to eight the eighth floor is
home to CEO Rupert Murdoch and his sons
this is the power behind the power look
our new shares and our opinion shows are
very different our news is impartial
it's top of the line our opinion shows
nature gave a voice to people who didn't
have one and he balanced the American
conversation I could pluck you out and
move you all the way to the front of the
line but I want something in return you
know what that is Kayla
loyalty I need to know that you're loyal
I need you to find a way to prove it hmm
you think about that all right
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
they have a contractual right to monitor
our communications a hotline in this
building is like a complaint box in
occupied Paris it's like we're telling
women go on speak up for yourself just
know the entire network is with Roger no
one will believe you they'll call you a
liar oh and as for your career you want
the Simons and airtime go ahead call the
paranoid man who decides your salary a
pervert and do that on a [ __ ]
anonymous hotline he controls on a phone
he has a contractual right to record
jesus [ __ ] christ do you think women
are idiots it's like somebody stripped
you naked and they want you to walk
through this office just to [ __ ]
prove it okay can I see you for a minute
former anchor gretchen carlson filing a
sexual harassment lawsuit against Fox
News chief Roger Ailes more women are
coming forward Hales is denying the
allegations and getting a goddamn Dairy
Queen you don't get to go and get
whatever you want everybody on my shows
knows the meaning of decency and I do
mean everybody I jumped off a cliff I
thought one of them would stand with me
hey mom hey room hey honey
there's a snack in the kitchen okay I
kind of get him it's Fox News has issued
some allegations of sexual harassment
allegations that you're over your boss
Roger Ailes what is your position on
this what do you think when you heard
this in this country every famous
powerful or wealthy person is a target
you're a target I'm a target
anytime somebody could come out and sue
us attack us go to the press or anything
like that and that's a deplorable
situation I've worked for Roger Ailes
for 20 years best boss I've ever had you
know I always find it so interesting who
history chooses to do something
important I guess listen I wanted to ask
you I wanted to ask you if Rogers are
asking you
how did you know
we find each other
you too
I'm down go wow
you okay
did you give my name to Megan by any
chance I'm I may have um worried about
you out loud
once or twice why didn't you just
support me Roger can sense
vulnerabilities in those days our
meetings were careers strategy sessions
mixed with good advice and comments like
the most basic thing is confidence feel
at home in your own skin if you're
confident you're sexy I'm sure you have
some sexy bras I'd love it to see in
those it was a cat-and-mouse game but he
always gave me good advice and let me
deflect tell him to dream on
the more I let him get away with the
more he pushed my buttons I don't know
if women can be good interviewers men
have that killer instinct and we do bad
things and we do not feel guilty about
it how can I be sure you have that that
kind of dry
I guess that means I pay for the food
that one of you puts in your mouth what
if it's you I'd have fired you for cause
Raja you built an amazing business no
one can take that away from you but
under the circumstances this is a lot of
money it won't look good to the people
that don't know your worth take it honor
your non-compete you will be muzzled
Gretchen
[Music]
maybe
please welcome Kazuhiro and Morgan and
Vivian Baker
[Laughter]
hello we're being watered now so
congratulations how fabulous great work
thank you very much well done
thank you so to get going first question
is going to go to Vivian and Morgan so
we'd like to begin with women presenters
of Fox which is a definitive look and
Charlize Theron as megyn kelly this is a
transformation at its foundation and
then the Fox look applied on top can you
share with us the details of your work
and the amalgam of makeup and
prosthetics and hair styles to create
this look this is for sorry this is for
the Megan Kellen character well I mean
Kazu did these amazing prosthetics which
gave the bones for us to create to Megan
Kelly you know the biggest thing was to
puts the tremendous amount of makeup on
top of those prosthetic that would be
required to give the flawless look that
was very much part of Fox and also just
you know how she would go to work so I
have to say the level of the prosthetic
was was paramount and me putting the
makeup on top of them which was
something that I had to create a way to
do so it was all they were I blended the
makeup so I would put a lot on by hand
and when it got to the prosthetics there
was a sealer that I would use that cause
II would build but there was also an
airbrush and I would build a different
base with a lot of different stuff in it
so as it walked over in a very you know
fine droplet way through the airbrush
that it would diffuse it not grab onto
the edges and stuff like that what I
think was kind of interesting when you
know seeing this reminded me you know
Kazu created this heavy eyelid that was
very megan kelly
and someone like megan kelly would do
everything she could to push that eyelid
back in her own makeup but that was not
anything that we could really do we
found that as we began to put the
yarmulke pon and to do that I needed to
leave it to show itself the the rest of
the makeup on her the liner
and those lashes were quite important
into shaping her the way that the lids
would go on sometimes they would you
know her eyes would be puffy would all
be different so every day it was
different was not I could not follow her
line I could not follow the shape of her
eye it was very artificially done and
curated and then almost close-ups
fortunately you couldn't tell how much
we had really gone outside of her shape
that's great well yeah I think in
creating Megan her particular looks are
documented and probably the most well
known of our characters and so it was
important to kind of hit those marks and
to keep a timeline oh is this the photos
behind me okay hey yeah I get a view too
so um you know when we started the the
short hair look that's showing right now
is something that was quite striking for
a character or rather a woman at Fox to
do to cut her hair off
you know Roger liked hair he liked the
specific kind of blonde he liked blondes
and so for her to cut her hair off I
thought that was really quite striking
because it was really ballsy you know
and I think she want to be taken more
seriously potentially as a journalist so
it was you know documented by the
presidential debate and so that was a
time frame that we had to mark with with
with megyn kelly she was our our
guideline of time through the film you
know so um yeah so there it was we
couldn't do it in the make it do what
but the hair was very helpful to talk
about a timeline because we couldn't do
it with the makeup yeah Kazu your turn
okay you're up you're up all right share
with us the process of using a
combination of established techniques
mixed with digital technology techniques
such as lifecasting an actor as well as
cyber scanning and what they gave you as
far as creating the the various
prosthetics yes so the I kind of started
to do life cast a calf is ago and the 3d
scan
at the same time right and freedom from
this show because I started realized we
we always struggle with a weight of them
impression material distort the face and
especially what lady the key point was
to change her eyelid shape and so I
needed an open eye life guest but every
time we try to do that it's all always
off so we I decided to use 3d scan and
print out and that as a positive mode to
kill scope the eyelid on and also the
nose plug I needed to you know like
because it's when I was started thinking
I I because it's so her nose nursery is
so dedicated and you know like a small
and if I put just put the you know like
a tube you know it would be store too
much so I had to figure out in the
design at the same time and so I decided
to take an impression inside of her nose
and on that on the negative shape I cut
in half and the scan the both side and
put in a digital ZBrush application and
the design there was a no show nose plug
because we only had like six weeks to
prepare all makeups and I knew I had to
change it right away and after
everything decided I had to print out
enough to do go through the whole
filming so you know it was good because
I could print 40 sets at the same time
and I only took like a one day to print
whole shooting nose plug yeah well Mason
you yeah yeah and so let's move on to
roger ailes play by john lithgow so here
we have their farewell so here on the
left of the screen is the life cast of
john lithgow and on the right the change
the appliances make can you talk us
through them touching upon the design
process please yes so I had a meeting
with
and we are talking about okay how much
of a likeness he wanted and also John
was a really spec script go about using
apathetic because he told me that he had
a bad experience in the past so but J
really wanted to change his look and it
was the important part to make John look
like a.j Lord and so J told me it should
be hybrid you know not like I exactly
look like a Roger but he wants to put
the essence in it so I took
characteristic of JLo sorry Lozier and
the big nose and the kind of Bulldog ish
cheek and a big neck and also producer
told me oh you cannot spend like a four
hours on set you know like a to apply
the makeup you know they always ask for
that so I designed this so it can be
applied under the three hours yeah and
it was really important because we don't
have we didn't have time and it has to
be applied really quick and also very
effective and but the good thing was the
first test makeup we did as soon as the
nose went on and the John's started to
realize okay there is a potential it's
really walking and so he was so excited
about every piece goes on and you know
he was looking at it and moving around
so the joint such an amazing actor and
they were great to walk with such a
sweet person yeah everybody was so great
actors in this film so yeah we really
enjoyed the process excellent
so here's a question another question so
you had over more more than 90
characters in the film and half of them
are look-alikes will you speak a little
bit about the work of some of the
characters in the film and the makeup
prosthetics and hair work that you guys
did there's there's a lot going on here
yeah there's quite a bit and you know
probably one of the most daunting things
just a few prosthetic characters that we
had to do cause she wasn't doing that so
I had to meet his quality you can only
imagine how
that would be so but we had there were
three with prosthetics and then we had
the others which had a lot of little
things but the three would be Tony plana
playing Geraldo Rivera and then there
would be Rupert Murdock being played by
oh my god asuka me a name forgot already
because I know Malcom McDowel sorry and
Richard kind playing Rudy Giuliani and I
don't know if we have a photo of him out
there a bit the Rudy Giuliani when was a
big four piece prosthetic to cover up
his hair it was quite fun to do I
thought it looked quite good in the rest
of them so I thought it was a great
transformation Vincent van Dyck built
the pieces in sculpting Richard
breathless and did some of that and Bart
Mixon we had some really good team
putting those on which was great the
rest of the makeups we did we
incorporated everything from mustaches
we did lots of lifts a lot of hand light
hair there were teeth they were contact
lenses and then there was just a lot of
really heavy forced beauty makeup right
really forcing the beauty makeup you
know it's like it was quite fun to do it
but forcing issues on women that you
know we don't always do and then how
about you as far as did you just have a
huge stash of wigs and ready to rock it
anymore
yeah no I
all trailer full of wigs to use right so
many staff so many people so many ways
no um I think that um yeah I think what
it was is we would take an actor when
they would arrive and and kind of see
what affectation we could use of their
own and in the likenesses I think maybe
more in the subject matter of the Fox
material and the Fox look and curating
that using the character of kala played
by Margot Robbie as the as a kind of our
prototype for a woman that would arrive
at Fox and maybe the journey of her
transformation so we used her as that
gauge and then we had the bevy of women
that would that did work at Fox that we
were playing you know replicating again
whether it's kimberly guilfoyle or
plethora of women
those we would have to be more specific
to their look and you know it was it's
that thing of more hair more fake in the
color you know very forced blondes and
it was just it was it was really like a
Barbie kind of end result and and and
oddly enough what you think is that we
can become quite used to being a normal
look but really we were so many laughs
and and not blended you know not to
blend and you can see in the beginning
with them with Megan Kelly even you can
see that her West's aren't moving but
they're not supposed to move you know
it's supposed to be for camera and just
be looking good for the cameras for you
so that is very specific and and and on
purpose so great thank you thank you
Morgan now we've got time for some
questions from our lovely audience here
just put your hand up and wait for a mic
to come to you I can't see a thing
because the lights are blinding me
so her mics not on Tammy's mics not on
thank you my question is for Vivian it
was just mentioned that 93 actors tell
me about your team like how many did you
have and like what did they have to do
like that's amazing to me that there
were 93 actors that you had to you and
your team had to take care of I know it
was a lot and it wasn't as big of a team
as I thought that I would have Christina
waltz was my key she's here tonight
today she's beautiful
and Richard Rev listen was a major part
of my team he also I shared him with
kazoo so he would be on prosthetic Sanh
roger ailes every day you know every day
that roger worked and when he was it he
was with me doing all this stuff so it
was very fortunate to have them and then
tara laying shaw who is also on my team
that was the main team i had an
assistant and there were two just help
us make sure that everything was there
megan Longmire and then the background
was run by Randy mattis Tron and Claire
Doyle and they I didn't have to think
about them because we had plenty on the
93 but as everyone would come in it was
literally like okay this is what we have
to do we had tons of research we knew
where we were where we wanted to go and
we tested every one until we got it
right and we just did whatever we had to
do answer your question sir
congratulations what a wonderful work my
name is Guillermo CEO from festival in
LA my question to you is how much you
have to research your characters because
you cannot fake something that we have
so much freshness in the viewers because
we see these those characters in TV
every single day and do we have very
fresh memories of these characters so
you can affect to us how they're gonna
look like in the actors in the real
movie so about your researching work
wants to take that case ooh-oh research
well basically you know like after we
read a script we just you know like the
great thing about now we have internet
and just gather up the images as much as
possible and also you know watching you
know YouTube you know it's a great great
age because we used to have to
you know raka right on the when I was
kid I was have to ride the bicycle to go
to the old liability to gather up the
images but now you can sit in a chair
and look but the thing is like a
sculpture II I usually collect like a
picture of each person in a straight-on
and three-quarter and profile and
because I don't want to mix too much
because it's very important to have the
picture the photograph taking at the
same time in a different angle and
that's a way to study a form and you can
talk about the makeup boys yeah we just
I mean our books were massive I mean I
had a like a digital you know collection
of photos that we've printed some
because it would have been way too much
to print them all and then the rest was
digital which was shared with my team so
that any point we could just pull it up
and take a look at it and as you create
the character you know each one you you
know every one you just have to find the
piece that embodies them you look at all
the images you can find out bits and
pieces but the big thing is like what
really sells it what really sells who
they are what did you need to change on
them there was just massive and massive
amounts of photos but they have that I
mean the good news is that these are all
news people they're quite well known so
it wasn't as difficult just trying to
find something you know when there was
no cameras around also I think that in
replicating there is something to be
said like you might think it's exact
exact exact and it seems that way but
the actors bring that to it as well you
know they bring on the affectations of
the movement and the speech or you know
whatever whatever intonation they need
to bring to it body language or whatever
so you are just trying to create you
know an affectation of it it's not the
character yeah I think we might have
time for one more question should there
be one out there I can't actually
indicate because the lights really do
first
congratulations to the team for just
amazing amazing job my question is for
Viviane so this is your your first
nomination you're a veteran makeup
artist you've been doing this a very
very long time and since the nomination
as one to hear how how this has affected
you personally to have to be able to
deal with this cinderella moment in your
life yeah who is that Michael key you
know I mean I'll be really honest with
you when I got called to do this job and
to work with Kazu I think that was
probably one of the highest marks I
think to work this film with Morgan and
with Kazu and to go all the way through
and to create this stuff I mean this
this kind of feels very unreal a bit of
the icing on the cake but I think at the
moment it was I mean I know his bar we
all do I know how high it is and just to
have stayed to the end of the film that
was probably one of the biggest things
that you know to make you happy I think
for me that's a big think the rest of it
maybe I'll feel it later
ask me in a month well that we've run
out of time but that congratulations
thank you it's really sincerely meant
[Applause]
our second film is Joker makeup and
hairstyle
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you need to eat skinny
sup ladies hey Thomas Wayne is a good
man
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's life that's what all the people
say
you're riding high
[Music]
cause this final
Hoyt said that they talked to you and
now they're looking for me I just want
to know what you said make sure our
stories line up seeing as how my boy
[Music]
how about another joke right now I think
we've had enough be a joke I don't
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
please welcome Nicky Lederman and Kay
Giorgio
[Applause]
hello welcome and congratulations super
work really is thank you
welcome right so the first question what
research was done to create the final
look of the Joker and how did you
achieve the look of Arthur Fleck well
the final look was really a
collaboration between the director and
Joaquin Kay and I and costume design as
well as much as production design
because it was really important that all
these elements come together so we can
complement each other and and really
create a mood that is in sync with each
other and when we first started the job
the director gave us a mock-up photo of
what he and Joaquin thought should be
the look of the the movie in terms of
like the clown look which then turn
becomes a joke a look because it's all
based on one design really and then it
was really for us to you know work it
out to you know get the placements right
get the colors right altered in a way
that is also safe for copyright because
clown makeups are actually incredibly
hard to recreate because they are copy
written that's actually this wonderful
book the clown registry of eggs I think
it is called it's like little eggs that
have the clown makeups painted on and
that's how they are all copy written and
and that's you know we got this book and
you know we had to make sure that it's
all clear that we didn't create
something that's all
been done before Wow Wow so tell us what
was the most difficult part when
executing the makeups and hairs we've
we've heard and we discussed sometimes
you had 20 minutes combined to get
joaquín ready and sometimes on the cuff
like having to re-establish makeups
after he washes his face and so on and
so on can you talk a little bit about
that well to begin with when we were
getting him ready what would work
together
gonna be nice today on good behavior
today we would work together I would be
when we were getting him ready for Joker
I would be putting the wig on and while
I was doing that Niki would be doing his
makeup at the same time so most days we
got it down to around 15 to 20 minutes
to you know the whole thing to get him
done and out of the chair the look for
Arthur was a lot quicker it was really
the the Joker was the bigger challenge
was yes
yes I mean I had to get his hair dyed
because walking has gray hair so I would
dye his hair but obviously I didn't need
to do that every day that was just a
maintenance thing and then just mess it
up put a load of product in it to get it
lookers to get it looking as unkempt as
I possibly could yeah and iPhone for
Arthur you know it was really he get
lost so much weight you know that the
the gaunt eNOS was almost there and all
I really had to do is like you know just
shade him a little more knock the red
out so he looks also a little paler and
that was really fast actually it was the
the the clown makeup and the Joker
makeup was the one that took longer
although we really couldn't spend much
time because you know I was not very
easy for working to sit still so it was
like constantly a moving target they're
like are you done and like let's get
going you know and that's also a reason
why we had to double-team that's why
everything went so quickly but yeah that
was pretty much the process well so now
okay what's a week and what is Rakeem
zone hair and can you
please talk about broccoli green yes
okay so what cane has gray hair so for
Arthur that's his own hair the picture
we're seeing now is the week once he
turns from Arthur into Joker it had to
be a week because of continuity we were
going backwards and forwards between
Arthur and Joker so the only way I could
do that was to just wick him
you see in the movie that he actually
dyes his hair on screen so I had to make
as close to his own hair as I could get
it and the the shade of green this this
broccoli green which is a story that
I've told a few times when we had the
first meeting with Todd it came about
the Joker has green hair what shade of
green and mark bridges the costume
designer said well it should be the
shade of broccoli so with that there's
this whole spectrum of broccoli green
there's you know there's the the yellowy
green there's charred broccoli there's
faded broccoli you know when it's old
Bronstein brought Claire
absolutely I mean there's all sorts of
garlic so this is non-organic yeah it
looks different you go to the
supermarket and you go to the broccoli
counter and you'll see this there's a
load of different too many have an eye
so I had a load of samples of different
shades of broccoli green and I took them
to Todd and I was like well what what
shade of green do you want and he he
picked number seven whatever shade of
broccoli that was and and then you know
I got the wig made and then actually
when we did the camera tests because of
course everything as you all know
everything changes once it goes under
the lighting it wasn't quite green
enough so I had to go back and like have
it pumped up so that in itself was a
little bit challenging because again
once it goes under the lighting one
she see him dye his hair in the in the
clip that you showed earlier when he
when he stabs the the clown in the eye
that's all wearing a wig but it doesn't
really show as green just because of the
lighting that's my broccoli green story
oh good that's a good dog
okay let's talk about there's a lot of
other clown makeups and there's a lot of
cast and then also all the blood
splatter which I really thought was
great can you talk a little bit about
that
well the clown makeups was the same
thing we had a bunch of different clowns
and we had to I had to come up with
clown makeups that haven't been done
before so that was like playing a lot
her husband to his hair he let me paint
on him a little bit and try to figure
things out and yeah again goes to the
studio they say yay or nay and in fact
the the clown that is sort of like the
bearded clown the hobo clown I think I
got like rejections three times until I
finally got to a design that was
approved and the blood splatter was
again everything had to happen really
fast and so the final blood splatter was
with me literally like running in and
like pour blood on my hand and then just
like like like you know and then once we
were done we took him to get him scanned
so that we could then recreate some of
the blood in if when we didn't get it in
other takes to replicate it but it was
all from from that original blood
splatter because again time was of the
essence and everything was very intense
and and and we didn't want to spend time
to clean up and do it again just because
of the whole he liked not sitting being
able to sit still and handling certain
things so that was the most easy and
fast way to deal with it and yeah that's
how we dealt with a blood splatter
excellent and so couldn't you tell us
about some of the products that you were
using
yes products I had to use actually a
bunch of different products in terms of
water soluble versus waterproof the
scene that beautiful scene in the
bathroom when he does this beautiful
dance actually go in we shot it for a
lot longer it actually goes to the point
where he goes to the sink and washes off
his face and so we had to reset it like
15 times behind the stage on an Apple
box with you holding a little I'd
remember because there was just no tying
my iPhone yes I'd like to match it
because we had to match it to the scene
where he after he killed the subway kids
so we had to match that for continuity
but also had to use products that were
water soluble so I can just like finish
cleaning it off and put it by right back
on and it had to come off on and off on
and off so water soluble products had to
be used which were mainly Matt krohmer
cake because they were the easiest to
work with as a water soluble product and
then I had to use waterproof products
for example when we were doing the
subway scene where he's getting chased
by the cops with a mask that was
actually the very first time we filmed
him as the Joker
and I was mortified because I didn't
know what's gonna happen is gonna smear
under the mask is it is you know is he
gonna let me touch him up because he
would always run the other direction and
so I had to kind of use you know
waterproof product to minim minimize the
touching up and running after him and
and in in a way it's kind of you know it
what kind of it worked great that way
you know like as little you kind of is
little dealing with it the better but
also if felt in a way also more organic
because sometimes what happens happens
and it's what that's reality and this
movie is about reality it's not
superheroes it's needed to be authentic
and real true great response thank you
now we have some time for questions from
our lovely audience just put your hand
up that's it
hello good that's that so we see what
keen applying the makeup with a brush so
I'm curious for timing did you use brush
or wheezing sponges or yes exactly what
do you use I gave him face when he
whenever he did his own makeup I we used
the tools that I would actually use when
doing his makeup so the brush that he
used is what I used when I did his
makeup it's outside you can actually
look at it
another question film on average how
many times you have to put on the clown
makeup do you mean in a day
oh or over the whole over the whole film
a lot I mean you know well you know when
you watch the movie it's like there's a
lot of Arthur Fleck without the clown
makeup and so I mean out of the 60 days
we shot I would say we probably had him
in some kind of a clown makeup at least
half of the time at least I would say
right I think that's about right it's a
very good question I don't actually know
but it's about half yeah it's like
another question out that high so when
the director said make it broccoli
colored so did you just go to the
grocery store and buy like 12 different
heads of broccoli and bring him in and
say which one do you like pretty much I
did go to the supermarket I did go to
the broccoli counter I did look at all
of the different shades and I also went
to the freezer section to look at what
frozen broccoli would look like and then
I went away and got some hair just like
yak hair which is white based I dip them
in a load of dylon which is a dye that
you use for clothes and got different
shades of the of these broccoli greens
and they're what I put in front of
director oh so you actually use like
swatches of hair I did I used swatches
of hair so when he had to green it up
did you use apples I'm so sorry what
when you had to green it up did you use
apples
I actually just use again it was just
the dial on to bump it up well sadly
we're running out of time though we
could chat all day but thank you and
thank you and congratulations you our
third picture is Judy makeup and hair
styling please show the clip you're my
favorite Judy
who else we had in Shirley Temple this
morning
everybody loves Shirley let's see how
Judy measures up what are we doing first
Bobbie usual said okay yeah gorgeous
sake I have your money Oh grants gonna
go crazy out there
oh so it's a hundred and fifty dollars I
know it's not maybe what do you steal
but no no guys we're gonna have to sue
you both sit don't stop
why are you even protecting us ed what's
going on oh shut up said you can't turn
up your one o'clock in the mornings
I know they should be in bed okay it
just doesn't always work that way
and it gets late because nobody wants to
pay to see me at 2:00 in the afternoon
and I have to work because they need
things they need an education Judy if
they need 10 hours of sleep just to hell
with this just call me I want custody
during the school year if kids Mickey oh
no no no no
well you shouldn't it's like living with
your heart on the outside of your body
no hamburger mr. mayor said very
specifically you were not to eat the
food I'm honestly very hungry those will
take the edge off
no I gotta sleep tonight
right so that was his lawyers on the
phone what he wants them Sunday through
Friday during school time no he claims
you're homeless
how's he even paying for a lawyer he's
not making money off me anymore so where
are you staying
I love my children I take care of them
welcome to the Picador thank you thank
welcome misko thank you I bet you you
fabulous Miss Judy Garland oh I just
adore London my home away from home
come with me thank you hello I'm Rosalyn
Wilder I'll be looking after you while
you're in London wonderful we can
discuss the songs if you really want to
label your charts so there any changes
you might like to make no everything the
same
is there anything to discuss then
sweetheart that's up to you I don't
particularly need to discuss anything
Judy I'm afraid the critics will review
opening night
sure course it's tomorrow
[Music]
we go boys
no matter what you mean you can't
there's an audience out there wait dear
you sing my mouth dry and it won't
listen to me we'll be fine now
oh what a wonderful surprise
Judy it's 12 o'clock and one there's a
thousand people upstairs waiting to hear
you sing
so bring another drink and Evan bring me
one too I know I know it's not easy oh
you do do you the shows the shows have
been a huge success Oh what does it
change anything what difference does it
make
[Music]
to the happy couple
cheers Cheers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's a lady up there well it back
your choice
Oh
Oh
way up high there's a land that I heard
of once in a lullaby
[Music]
[Applause]
you want
you miss you want
unfortunately Jeremy's not able to be
here he's on a film but he did write a
letter so let me go to read the letter
hello governor's fellow nominees
esteemed makeup artist and hairstylist
and guests I'm so sorry I cannot be with
you this afternoon I'm held up in
traffic literally I am probably about
32,000 feet above Montana right now I'm
working on a movie back in London and
unfortunately couldn't get away any
earlier to join you at the symposium I
am with you in spirit and hope you're
having a wonderful time everybody having
a wonderful time
yep good a few words about Judy it's
rare the stars align and we end up
working on a film that is challenging
work but that is also great fun to work
on Judy was just such an experienced
having to turn one well-known face into
another when the two had so little in
common in common physically was a
challenge that called
on input from a great team we needed a
beautiful nodded wig from Natasha Mladic
transformative teeth and contact lenses
from Fang effects and real I company the
most subtle of prosthetics to change
Rene's nose not an easy place to hide a
prosthetic so thank you animated extras
I was backed up by a fantastic team of
makeup artists Rob Deborah Renata and
Barbara who showed a talent only matched
by their dedication we completed the
shoot in less than seven weeks which
meant that there was no luxury of
spilling over to another day locations
were only available for the days that
were booked so we had to get all the
cast on set on time in under 90 minutes
every single day and the budget was so
tiny so running into overtime was not an
option in spite of the intense work the
film was a joy to work on and that was
largely down to our wonderful leading
lady the best makeup artist assistant
out there if anyone here has the chance
to work with Renee Zellweger stop at
nothing she is the best Thank You Jeremy
um obviously since Jeremy is not here we
won't have a QA right Jeremy so yeah so
thank you our next film our next film is
Melissa Fionn mistress of evil
makeup hair styling and prosthetics
please show the clip
well
presenting Queen Aurora of the Moors
[Music]
[Music]
mother when in the Moors and one left
behind by her father King Stefan was it
not that castle was never my home it was
given to the people so you're also a
true princess
even though Stefan died was killed
remind me did he die or was he killed
both
[Music]
do you hear it
do you hear it huh it's a message from
the humans I hear it loud and clear
time faster dies humans have used iron
against us for centuries and we are
almost extinct because of it killing
presence on the moors will only lead to
more conflict Nora
they pulled the iron from the earth made
their swords and shields drove us
underground this this finishes our
people are safe here for now how long
the humans will find us they will not
stop
I caught the wall
when Dogface
same as you
[Music]
all the delayed as more human kingdoms
emerged we went into hiding from every
corner of the earth doing what we had to
do survive
but many were lost
[Music]
tundra the forest the jungle
now our only refuge is here in this cage
our nest of origin
[Music]
[Music]
those children should be soaring over
the trees and rivers instead they're
raised in exile I could protect them by
waging war against the humans I've been
at war with them my whole life
not all of them there was one you raised
as your own
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
from lived abroad
we've been tells that the other kinds
find their seats part but I'm not a
human and remain what
[Music]
get out before I call the guards if
you've done your pixie Oh dare you call
me that
I'm lickspittle Tonopah I serve the
Queen our fight begins
stand down this is not my fight my
mother wanted a war and you're giving it
down I won't allow her hatred to ruin my
kingdom or yours
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
please welcome Paul Gooch Arjun tooten
and David White well welcome such
smashing work well done thank you thank
you that's great
hold it like an ice-cream that's right
so Aryan we're gonna start with you
could you share with us the details of
the prosthetic pieces in your process of
applying the Maleficent makeup on
Angelina Jolie yeah basically what she's
wearing is cheetah prosthetics and nose
prosthetic she has teeth she has ears
when she's not wearing a head head wrap
and she obviously she has the horns that
make up took about two and half hours
Tony G who I wish was here did a
beautiful beauty makeup and Audrey did
her hair are Eastern and so we would
start with the hair wrap that would go
it would get tied into the horns and so
the bulk of the hair was gone
and as soon as that was done we I would
start with the prosthetics and and then
I will move on to the foundation Tony
would do start one of the eyes and we
would switch spaces and we just had this
whole routine going and there's a
combination of foundations and obviously
airbrushing and yeah
thank you nice Paul and David this
brings us to the other characters that
we see you working on here would you
share the design and execution of the
characters as well as the Fae and the
woodland the phase of the woodland
jungle and forest and also I saw there's
a really attractive Fae that was in one
shot Thank You Howard
yeah very handsome
yeah a spinoff script will be written
right I figured that'll be the next one
it's about you okay I mean we had a it
was it was an interesting thing because
the production design gave us a real
lead as to how these characters were
getting work I mean the director was Sam
what so what are the other fail of like
were they look like and it really came
down to their environment which was the
key to it and the fact that we were
going to use camouflage as a way of
showing kind of how they can merge into
those environments
so with jungle and with tundra and with
desert you notice that they basically
using the colors of those environments
and we're using feathers for the tundra
you know white feathers and things so
that's kind of how it evolved for all
these characters and Paul what did you
have anything yeah we were with the hair
over David's prosthetics there that was
a bit of a major thing wasn't it to try
and secure these horns two heads because
they had to do all sorts of stunt work
so without creating bulge and keeping
the head shapes so within the hair is
also reflected biomes of desert tundra
jungle those things so it's a foliage
feathers that kind of thing the girl in
the middle at the bottom there that wig
was actually braided with different
colors throughout and you needed to see
her scalp as she would with braiding so
she was entirely bald captain that the
wig was an absolute work of art made by
Ray mastan's team that was the hardest
one to achieve of all of them
and then I see of course you can't do a
film like this without Warwick Davis
he's gotta have Warwick yeah he was
terrific for Warwick yeah I mean he's
great
originally this was gonna be a CG
character so it had I had to use
elements of the CG character and kind of
merge it into Warwick's life cast you
know and there were certain elements of
Warwick that we've seen before in
different movies and I was trying to get
away from that so Albert Einstein in a
certain age was a guy
tract for how things were going with
he's in that kind of you know that went
really well for the director and
everyone was happy wonderful so I'm
going to ask each of you what was your
biggest challenge on the film
starting with you Dave oh I knew you I
mean to be honest it's when you say it's
a pair of horns but then they said to me
listen you've got thirty five of these
guys and the trouble is they're all
individual lifecast so we literally had
to had cast everybody each individual
piece is determined by their hair their
real hair because of how you lock it in
so that was a real challenge just to get
the cap to fit exactly as tight as it
can be so Paul can do his magic and then
also you know we had issues with the
cheeks and everything but you know
they've got ears so all these things
were sculpted on their own life casts
and some of them were trance trance
taken down onto the onto a flat and then
reproduced so all sorts of technical
issues along route I think their sheer
numbers of people who had to look so
extreme and there's always a time limit
isn't know that you never have enough
time and I went to every wig maker and
they were all refusing me in the end so
we actually had to bring people into the
studio and put them in a big tent and
make stuff on site because particularly
with my RV the white Hey because Angie
actually changed how she wanted him to
look before we actually got to shoot him
so we had a really short turnaround to
get those things changed on him so I
would say but the most challenging thing
was was say the numbers of people and
the time that we had to do it I mean I
remember every week the big producer
would haul us all into a room and say
right where are we now how is that going
to be achieved we've got a countdown of
so many days and you know that's a real
pressure but we pulled it off in the
ending we with the hundreds of other
people that helped us do it cause
venerian it's just keeping the
continuity really answer very
precise makeup obviously for obviously
reasons because it's in the middle of a
face all these pieces and you notice a
time constraint I think we applied it 60
days you know every day of two and half
hours and she also showed the
prosthetics actually in which I forgot
to mention just kind of kind of bring
that shape out but yeah just keeping a
good timeline and keeping her happy
really so you said you applied at sixty
days yes
Wow and were there days other than the
weekend did with the production
accommodate four days off here and there
just like no she just had two weekends
off but I have to say we took very good
care of her skin and Tony's crazy Tony
is amazing with that and just because
you know is such an important woman and
next to that you just don't want to do
anything dead yes so if there was there
something that you absolutely didn't
know before you began this film that you
do know now or no to and when you wear
them you feel as if they should be there
it's a weight as if we should all have
had them I think yeah I get used to
wearing that I know yeah that is true
but I tell you the one thing is the
weight ratio with the horns you know
because some of these guys I made the
horns really long and really you know
tall so it's all very well doing that
but then you know it's so high that you
can't have any wobble so the material
you make it out of and if you go solid
materials or semi rigid then it's it's
heavier so you're kind of you know
you're battling the yeah they look
easier than the actual yeah there's all
sorts of technical you know at the Aten
trying to get anchorage sufficient and
then sort of sharp anchors to those on
people's heads without actually making
holes in their scars we looked at so
many vegetables too oh we did we did
I want to know if you tried any tails on
to go with the horns the way did you try
any tails on tails yeah well just
because of you know horns and Tails oh I
see well I think we're going to the
audience now so questions please oh
you've got pip to the post here's some
hello hi um so I just have a question of
how you merged horn to hair and then
secured hair to head like how did you do
that Wow shall I start
that's like to join that deal yeah
because I mean again it starts with the
the quantity of hair they have as an
actor or an actress and then from then
it's a question of figuring out I mean
we used all sorts of leather little thin
leather areas underneath the caps as
well and then we had gauze areas cut in
within the pieces within the hats the
skull caps themselves which would also
help anchor the the hair down we had a
lot of different techniques because
everybody into natural hairstyles were
so different yeah and it with each
different person you know sometimes you
reduce some of their own other time it
was a full wig it just depended what the
look was also people's sort of endurance
for how much metal they can cope with
for some of them it was like when you
put a wig on you just you wrapped the
hair you put those little flat toupee
clips I don't I'm sure all the
hairdressers in the room know about
those and then you stick that pin
underneath it but some actors you can't
even walk in the room and ear with one
of those and they start screaming at you
blur as I say it was different for each
person
my question is about the palette you
used for Angelina Jolie they it's
exquisite and I love her eye color her
lips how did that develop that kind of
developed on the first film actually
about six years ago
and she was very specific about the red
if you want it red and I think we Tony
tried about 40 different types of red
and eventually Mac had to custom make a
red because no Reds were good enough and
so it just goes on and on but I have to
give credit to to Tony and and just an
Angie coming up with some brilliant
ideas obviously a Christina Peterson
Paterson did some beautiful lenses and
you know they did a lot of research in
that but and then the foundations they
varied from because they often have like
silicone and and and and Vaseline in
them so because of the pieces it's just
a combination of different products
really but and they have a question
right here Oh keep your hand up so they
can spot you hello thank you I'm so
honored to be able to ask you a question
a beautiful finishing touch and the film
is the hands and the nails of some of
the characters how is that you know is
that your guys's creativity or does that
come from the team and do they wear
those throughout the filming or is it
something that gets done every day yeah
all the other ladies so the females have
nails from their different biomes they
all have nails and they're all hand
painted and finished and they're applied
everyday for the guys we had kind of
silicon caps made and they had to come
on and off you know but so that it
wasn't like a stuck prosthetic but it
extends them around you know 1/2 inch
1/4 to 1/2 inch on some of them and
there's some of those being Universal
but we ended up we ended up molding
everybody's fingers and reducing the
cause on everyone so that they were a
tight fit and then that rolled them on
there's a few out in the foyer you can
see how they work and they and the color
as well because everybody's hands
individual colors for each character and
we had a spare set for everybody and I
had these little kind of goodie bags
made so they could keep the space
everybody here gets a bag of fingers but
in
really I never feet there were feet
- oh you know there were nails on the
feet - Peter had a question yes thank
you first of all congratulations a
wonderful work I love the way the blend
between the the the hair the makeup and
even the over look I was wondering where
did the CGI come in with the wings and
and was that through orchestration of
your your artistry and I'm yeah for
Angelina they were obviously visual
effects something you did build some
wings in the first film there yeah we
built some wings for Angelina for
reference on our first wings which we
used and we had those wings again which
we use for our other characters to stand
you know in front of as a guide track
because it's it is kind of odd when
you're not when you haven't got those
wings you know it really helps to know
how it carries on as it well because the
jungle characters their wings extremely
colorful exotic colors and that's going
to be reflected in their body painting
and their and their makeups you know so
it was really important I went to the
art department and I got these kind of
blow up blush and blown up versions of
these wings and had a character stand in
front of them so we could use them for
guide tracks yep oh that's that's
fascinating actually thank you very very
much and congratulations thank you
wonderful work wonderful
[Applause]
our next film is 1917 makeup and
prosthetics for the entire film please
share the clip
they call me sergeant I'm sorry you're
right from sorry welcoming me through
orders from the general get out of the
way I've got to say careful that you're
stepping on the deck
that's our sergeant we've got washing
them out just dugout with a bloody hose
do you know where the orcs are next bend
you'll be standing on top of our for
them shut the hell - nice
York's escorting where's major Stevenson
I just killed a couple of nice couple
left n unless he has come on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
stay there chop-chop
stop stop
so much yeah
have some like
came to motel needs water no no no we
have to stop the bleeding
come on
yes yes I think you are change happen to
him
Vince your wife will stop with
embellishments the entire expedition we
thought no your board bloody awful
you don't know they'll even speak the
body language he's got a fella craftsman
at the dooku carnage on the rock
[Music]
I'm trapped
[Music]
this one yet there's nothing
sickness toil nor danger in that bright
land to which I go I'm going to see my
father I'm going there no more too
major yes sir if you can walk move to
the triage area
lieutenant Blake
when it's Grubnic
it was very quick I'm sorry
[Music]
you
please welcome Naomi done Tristan for
suus and Rebecca Cole unfortunately
Rebecca can't be with us well
congratulations
terrific work really was so we're going
to start with please can you share with
us your process of doing makeup changes
through the film since it's being told
in real time and gives the impression of
being one shot yeah that was the initial
big problem or challenge that we had to
have the makeup changes had to be mapped
out the shots it wasn't one shot
obviously but it was 30-something shots
so because we'd rehearsed so much we
knew the camera angle all the way
through for every single shot so for
instance when Blake gets stabbed we knew
that we were starting on George at the
water pump and that the camera would pan
round and we'd see Blake in the distance
quite far away so we could put a pale
makeup on him and by the time the camera
pushed in he'd already lost a lot of
blood so he it seemed authentic that
he'd be that pale at that time so we
could we could map things all the way
through and you know there are problems
because you can't can't go in put blood
place the blood and so Tristan had to
build a rig that was remote-controlled
so that and he had to time it exactly so
that the blood start is squirting out
from his stomach at exactly the right
moment that was a little bit of a
problem no pressure right
what did you do in your spare time so
would you would you share the makeup
design an application on Benedict
cumberpatch on his character look yes
well you can do that Tristan yeah I
remember
Benedict saying when we had to sort of
meeting with him that he wanted a little
bit of history to the character so we we
talked about a scar and his eye but I
think I think Sam didn't want anything
too dramatic to take away from it so
yeah we discussed this kind of little
ice car which made a little little bondo
that applied nice and quickly on the day
and kind of lined it up to a really
beautiful contact lens that was made by
Cristina and yes we wanted the wound to
go exactly right through so they wound
in his eye was matched up to the wound
on his face how many how many I know
that there was limited shots or the lens
or what happy how many days did he play
that about one day now although some
supporting actors like Benedict and I
Colin Firth Andrew Scott and they all
were on from one day pretty much the
mark Strong was the only one needed to
but they came in cold to pick up that
pick up where we all were in that movie
and just come up with it they were very
they were never they weren't involved
with any of those big rehearsals or
anything like they were they were
involved in the rehearsals quite early
on and then we didn't seen them for
months then suddenly there they were
yeah it's hard it's hard when you've got
Richard Madden for instance who's doing
the last scene in the movie and it's a
very emotional scene and they were
really worried those guys they were so
committed to the film I so wanted to be
in it and they pulled it off they were
right so while we're talking about that
and what was the biggest prosthetic
challenge in the film well I'll pass
over to you but I just like to say that
the M scene where they're in the medical
tent which Tristan then built tonnes of
prosthetics for Sam initially didn't
want a lot of prosthetics he didn't want
it to be too ghoulish right so so um but
he didn't fit when we rehearsed it the
day before he felt something wasn't
quite right so he got up really early
and had to think in the field he went
into the field another thing and thought
I think this needs to be more gory and
he finds like me as ney I've changed my
mind I want it really bloody gory and
then I rang Tris and went oh [ __ ] yeah I
freaked out he pulled it out I mean we
had prepped it we prepped it but we
didn't think we'd ever need it
so over to you for the rest of it well I
mean yeah that scene I mean it was a
huge challenge to get all those those
extras ready and the different levels of
wounds the quantity like the quantity
overnight changed so I woke up the
morning kind of had to prep my crew and
kind of like okay guys you know
yesterday remember yesterday he's kind
of like three times that but it was it
was the challenge I mean it was the
levels of the blood that the debris you
know we had a whole variety of different
wounds small from the small scratches
through to heavy wounds and amputees and
we had a lot of amputees who Tris had
built you know just like sleeved things
that go it went over the remains of
their limbs all motorbike accidents
anyway I'm sorry so that was all done
that was all prepped but we then decided
to use them more so but you had to get
your crew like okay like you just said
like okay go have a couple pints and
then you're like okay hold on wait a
minute we're gonna go exactly we're
gonna jump in this now right but they
were great I mean they they hit the
challenge and they just had a few more
people in that chair that morning very
cool um will you uh let's talk about the
what was the biggest challenge with
continuity on the character's skull
field as he goes through so much like it
really it's one thing after another
Rebecca Cole who should have been here
she's pregnant so she couldn't make the
flight she she's very very anal really
completely the opposite of me and that's
why I put her in charge of joy because I
just knew that she would not let
anything slip but the biggest challenge
was what you're looking at now the
sequence where he gets buried in the
rubble we shopped the only scene we shot
out of sequence and of course it has the
biggest effect on his appearance we had
to first of all we had to find a dust
that we could
all over his face and into his mouth and
eyes that was non-toxic that wouldn't
hurt him that was safe to breathe in
and David's Toman at makeup came up with
an idea of using a sugar it's a sugar
sort of substitute that he ground we had
so many different grinds we've got some
outside there as well and we had so much
the color at the set and in the end it
actually worked really well because it
dissolved slightly his mouth and when he
coughs all that muck comes up which I
wanted I wanted to see that because
first you think he's dead and then it
all comes out and and the scene after
that we showed where he's washing it off
heartbreaker really got to me actually
and then we had the continuity that
Rebecca had to deal with was that we
shot all of that stuff before we
actually shot that scene so we rehearsed
that scene a lot in reality we buried
him and then we filmed it and then we
referred to that all the time and and it
sort of worked in the end that was a
really really big chairman and I mean
he's a pretty special actor to let be
covered like that I mean when I just
watched that clip I'm like he's like
public parish I'm sure Sam was like
let's cover him up and then you got to
put those rocks and I mean he's pretty
climbing it because he can't breathe so
your timing and it seemed like ages
let's go let's go let's go because I've
known him since he was a baby so I had
even more attachment oh yeah factor
Georgia how lovely
so could you can you talk about research
and where that began well I started
researching the minute Sam sent me that
scripts and which is June before we
start in almost a year before he started
shooting and obviously there's a huge
amount available online I went to the
Imperial Museum we looked at tons of
documentaries I bought tons of
documentaries and then it was the Peter
Jackson documentary that really gets to
you because it's colorized you it feels
somehow more real even more real but you
see in 3d there was a 3d version it was
absolutely fast I didn't I just say yeah
yeah bit late now
thank you very much what the things you
take though from documentary footage
where it's pure it looks Oh period
because of the way the films shot but
and that same with Ricky and so is I
used to have that really pale almost of
bluey whitish hue that the soldiers
seemed to have in the documentary
footage so we actually did that with all
those extras we we mixed a blue into all
into a little foundation to knock off
any red that they had and just make them
look I don't know why it gave us lightly
period feel to make them to knock off
all of that but so there's so much
there's so much available research-wise
which and you can sit in your chair and
the armature you don't need to cycle to
the library and but there are certain
pictures that really struck me as a
picture of a man in a trench he was just
covered in mud with his head in his
hands in such despair and that was the
picture I had on from my make-up place
to because I felt that we had to honor
all of these soldiers and that was the
way I did it I think and but also in the
room with the extras I plays we played
documentaries all the time
as well as all the photos that you
always have our pin for reference but we
had the documentaries running on a reel
so that all the soldiers who were
waiting to go into hair and makeup would
sit there and look at it and absorb it
and I think realize then how how
important it was that they portrayed all
of these soldiers with real honesty and
authenticity just to respect
oh this made me go quite seriously don't
get angry
does it's important that we do that in
our work questions from our lovely
audience please pop your hand up
hi
so there have been so many television
shows and movies that are about what
were these horrible wars when you got
the call in the script from Sam what did
you think you needed to do differently
because it's a revelation just watching
him with interacting with the bodies and
the horses so what did you do
specifically to make it different well I
just wanted to be very authentic so
things like you're looking at now we had
a lot of rotten teeth I suppose that's
what that photo that's about the same
what I wanted to do is portray the lives
of the soldiers in their faces and in
their hair so and that was more research
that was talking to historians for
instance about a day in the life of a
soldier or what they had to go through
things like their haircuts were very
specifically strange in World War one
they were very different to World War
two which is longer on top but World War
one they first of all they clipped their
hair and then to take away any
individuality and then the guys put
their helmets on and you weren't allowed
to have any hair showing out underneath
their helmets but they'd keep growing it
sort of out of defiance and then they
cut these fringes across so that it
wouldn't show under their helmets and
you ended up with these really weird
haircuts and I what I just wanted to get
those weird haircuts and we had really
funny ones and you saw a lot of them in
that scene where the soldiers singing
and you the camera pans around all of
those faces and we got there and sang
goes I want all very helmets off and I
went oh my god when were they checked
last so we literally went round with
clippers and a chair got nail scissors
at one point does it guy with a friend
I'm just hacking it off because I didn't
check them for a week and they grow out
so fast and but anyway what I wanted to
be different was the fact I didn't want
any vanity I wanted rotten teeth I
wanted boils on their neck
I wanted bad tattoos and all of that
stuff I just wanted them to look exactly
as they would because they've been
through hell number
can that's how I want supertrash another
question can you talk about the dead
bodies you have anything to do with the
dead bodies and also the process of
dying because we seen in a short period
of time like in seconds turning blue and
change the color of dine at the moment
because of the continuity take yeah I
mean we made a lot of dead bodies for
the sequence no man's land and River
sequence it was that we have various
levels of decay in them and they were
all fully articulated fully here punched
and everything because they had to so be
buried in the mud and set into the
landscape and so feel like they'd been
there for a long time or a short time it
depending on the teepee got into
no-man's land for example and then the
body sequence again we had a lower
bodies have been washed up against a
tree so likewise they saw had bloated
ones and different kind of we had
villagers and soldiers but they they had
to solve or be anchored down and be
fully interactable because george had to
so climb over them which when i was or
building them was terrifying so i'm like
they're gonna fall apart and it's not
going to work but yeah we made quite a
few just to sort of give that sense of
loss in the landscape of the war zone
sort of thing so and the Blake's death
where he does go blue that was a sort of
lucky break because there was a blending
point which is what we called the places
where we cut and and then moved on and
that had to be blended so it all looks
like one shot we had a blending point
before Dean is dragged off by those
soldiers looking seriously dead so we
were able to punch up his makeup before
beforehand so we could get that blue
change another question
is that someone that when when the one
guy is in the explosion and the
underground he comes out he's called the
dust on his face I just wonder which
what you guys used for that that was
like safe for him to have in his eyes
and its mouth and stuff well that was a
sugar as of something derived from a
sugar the substance that's out there in
the front you can have a look at it and
it's not sugar but it's something sugary
that we have this man David Stone who
makes all our special effects makeup he
made all the dirt we matched all the
dirt to the ground where we were
shooting we were shooting in three
different locations and we matched it to
all to that and he made that that's
white substance so it's completely safe
to breathe in or to have in your mouth
or in your eyes any other questions yes
I need to know how much um human anatomy
and physiology that you guys a research
and like again the timing of how glued
the person is they're dying I'm a
physician so I'm amazed at you you
matched it so well and I just wondering
is it just your artistic approach to it
or is it actually human anatomy and
physiology research and the second
question is sorry I'm sneaking in a
second one director Sam Mendes has a
little Caribbean in it and in a year
Oscar so white I'm glad that he in 1917
now you have Indian East Indian
character and I saw a black character
what approaches do you have for when
you're doing makeup and whatnot for
people of more diverse skin and color
thank you well what's the first bit I
think the first bill was as far as I can
atomy and yes we do actually have to
study well it's not that you study at B
research it so when you have bodies that
ripped open Tristan will know his
studied a lot of horrible images but
yeah I'm kind of
you kind of get a lot of online research
a lot of medical books and that kind of
stuff I mean it's it's hard to look at
but you kind of have to base it on
reality so yeah and and as far as Sam
goes he is a mixture of many diverse
bits and pieces I think and and when
you're doing diverse we're different
colored skin or different ethnicities
it's the same you know you you it's the
same as any makeup you take a skin tone
and you create your makeups that work
with the skin tone well thank you and
well done so at this time I'm going to
ask all of our nominees to go to your
tables please and I would also like the
audience to please give the artists a
few minutes to get down to their splays
and then you are welcome to go
downstairs and see some of their
beautiful work and talk to them I want
to thank all of you for attending today
and I also wanted to say please watch
the Oscars tomorrow night thank you
you